place à votre journal de l'afrique sur
france 24 est heureux de vous retrouver
à la une ce soir ce nouveau bras de fer
entre l'onu et le mali la junte expulse
le porte parole de la minus ma motifs
ses prises de position après
l'arrestation des 49 soldats ivoiriens
le kenya en mots que de jeunes électeurs
- 5 % en cinq ans triste constat trois
semaines des scrutins présidentiel et
parlementaire rencontre avec cette
jeunesse décourager et puis des toupes à
montréal où se tient le festival de
musique nuits d'afrique jusqu'au 24
juillet 36e édition sur place notre chef
d'orchestre fatimata one
il a 72 heures pour quitter le mali la
junte expulse le français olivier
salgado porte parole de la minus marin
nouvel épisode dans l'arrestation des 49
soldats ivoiriens bamako en cause des
tweets publiés dans la foulée de cette
interpellation des provocations selon
les autorités maliennes charlie sheen
bon
note olivier salgado porte parole de la
minus ma mission de l'onu au mali
désormais persona non grata à bamako
mercredi les autorités maliennes donne
72 heures au porte parole pour quitter
le pays elles l'accusent d'avoir posté
sur twitter des publications
tendancieuses concernant l'arrestation
de 49 soldats ivoiriens le 10 juillet
les autorités maliennes arrête ces
militaires affirmant qu'il s'agit de
mercenaires
ils ont été immédiatement interpellés
leur armement munitions et équipements
ont été saisis
abidjan dément ces accusations
les militaires serait arrivé en toute
légalité avec l'accord de l'onu
olivier salgado appuie la position
ivoirienne dans cette série de tweets
les soldats seraient des éléments
d'appui logistique aux troupes
ivoiriennes
d'après nos informations écrites il le
relève du 10 juillet aurait été
préalablement communiqués aux autorités
nationales
les relations se sont tendues
graduellement entre la gente militaire
au pouvoir au mali et ses partenaires
internationaux dont mission et de
ramener la stabilité et la sécurité au
pays début 2022 bamako pousse les forces
françaises dehors l'ambassadeur de
france est expulsée le 14 juillet le
mali annonce la suspension des rotations
militaires et policières de la minus
marc
thomas boni yayi est à conakry l'ancien
président béninois dirige la mission de
médiation de la cedeao en guinée il doit
s'entretenir avec la junte le colonel
mamadou mamadou doumbouya a déjà
rencontré le dirigeant de l'institution
et celui de la commission d'instance
objectif le convaincre de revenir sur la
durée de transition à la tête du pays
après avoir renversé alpha condé il
s'est engagé à remettre le pouvoir aux
civils d'ici trois ans trop long répond
l'organisation ouest africaine elle
propose deux ans comme au mali et au
burkina faso elle veut éviter à la
guinée des sanctions au 1er août
aso djihadistes ou représailles entre
communautés que s'est il passé dans la
nuit du 14 au 15 juillet dans le nord du
togo quatre villages ont été attaqués
une dizaine de personnes a été tué selon
des médias locaux parmi elles de
nombreux civils et c'est parce que les
circonstances sont floues que
l'opposition demande une enquête
indépendante
rejoindre le burkina faso depuis le
niger en bus un trajet auquel ne se
risquent plus des milliers de voyageurs
la raison la multiplication des attaques
terroristes ces derniers mois a terra
par exemple au nord-ouest de niamey la
menace est grande sur place harold
gérard pour france 24
nous sommes allant des arrêts de bus de
la ville de terrain ce matin seulement
deux des véhicules de transport
partiront en direction du burkina faso
les passagers ne sont plus assez
nombreux pour justifier davantage de
départs durant la tente le stress se
fait ressentir particulièrement depuis
le 16 mars dernier l'un des groupes
terroristes actifs dans la zone avaient
attaqué un bus et tué au moins 19
personnes
aujourd'hui seuls ce jeune homme
acceptera de me parle je ne voyage
presque plus maintenant on a vraiment
peur tu peux apprendre n'importe quand
qu'on a attaqué tel ou tel bus à cause
de cette peur les gens prennent de moins
en moins les transports pour traverser
la frontière l'une des dernières
attaques enregistrées au niger est celle
d'une patrouille le 14 juin dans la
localité de houara ou proches de tera
bilan huit gendarmes a battu eux mêmes
sont souvent isolés face au danger
il n'y a que deux postes qui sont
proches l'un de l'autre sinon toutes les
autres casernes de gendarmes sont très
éloignées les unes des autres
ce jour là le président nigérien mohamed
bazoum est présent à terra la nouvelle
étape d'une tournée dans la région de
tillabéri pour promouvoir le retour des
déplacés internes chez eux une ambition
mise à mal par la recrudescence des
violences terroristes dans la zone nous
ne croiserons bas et celle qu'ils vont
être créés chez nous que nous tolérions
que nos populations quittent le village
quel est ce leur village à des terrasses
et qu'elle converge vers des centres où
elle passe à voir plus de protection
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
d'aucune annulation
soit ramené à ces derniers mois
plusieurs compagnies de transport ont
suspendu par période leur trajet entre
le niger et le burkina faso depuis le
début de l'année 22 dans la région de
tillabéri les incidents violents ont
déjà augmenté de plus de 30% par rapport
à 2021
le 9 août prochain le kenya élira le
successeur douroux kenyatta la tête du
pays en lice raïla odinga le chef de
l'opposition et william ruto qui occupe
actuellement la vice présidence un
scrutin qui n'intéressent pas les jeunes
peut en effet sont inscrits sur les
listes électorales pourtant trois
kenyans sur quatre ont moins de 35 ans
problème face au chômage à la corruption
et aux promesses non tenues difficile de
motiver les troupes notre équipe est
allée à la rencontre de cette jeunesse
désabusée reportage de viviane lembert à
bastien renouil elodie cousin
la vallée du rift région acquise à
william routot l'un des principaux
candidats à la présidentielle a le plus
grand nombre d'électeurs enregistrés
pour le scrutin du mois d'août pourtant
dans la ville d'eldoret grégory fred peu
attention et préfère se concentrer sur
son entreprise pour les politiciens sont
les mêmes les histoires sont les mêmes
il n'y a aucun changement et la
souffrance est toujours là
tout cela m'épuise quand il sera l'heure
de voter je ne suis pas sûr de me
déplacer
il n'est pas le seul à hésiter
désabusés les 18 35 ans sont moins
déplacés que d'habitude pour s'inscrire
sur les listes électorales
le nombre de jeunes votants a baissé de
plus de 5% depuis la dernière élection
ce qui inquiète les activistes de 6 à sa
place depuis 2015 ils se battent pour la
place des jeunes en politique mais selon
kent à leur démotivation s'additionnent
l'inaction des pouvoirs publics
je ne pense pas que le gouvernement
souhaitait réellement enregistré de
nouveaux jeunes électeurs et des tasses
cette fois ci le gouvernement d'abord
vesti attend d'eux donc avant de passe
ce serait qu'ils sont
alors une nouvelle génération de
politiciens tentent de les convaincre à
la proche du scrutin pour maurice kheneg
l'actuel gouvernement préfère miser sur
les plus âgés ils se réunissent avec son
équipe de campagne pour trouver comment
les amener à voter
le but est que les jeunes demain
nous devons protéger cette personne mais
nous ne voulons pas qu'il perde son
siège car il nous a permis d'améliorer
notre vie il nous a montré comment
gagner plus d'argent et c'est grâce à ça
quel quart de rond espoir
d euros en 2010 est l'actuel
gouvernement avait également misé sur la
jeunesse qui représentait alors plus de
51% des électeurs
mais désormais ceux-ci attendent plus de
leurs élus
plus de 700 artistes 150 concerts nuits
d'afrique a pris ses quartiers à
montréal jusqu'au 24 juillet 36e édition
de ce festival dédié aux musiques
africaines et caribéennes amadou et
mariam tiken jah fakoly alpha bondy tous
les grands sont passés par là sur place
fatimata one pour france 24 à ses côtés
de l'artiste congolaise max
[Musique]
d aladdin l'accord du dimanche 24
juillet
à peu près 150 couverts réactivité est à
l'étude
[Musique]
et
parmi eux il y à une pépite et moi
personnellement j'adore cet appel lundi
démocratique du congo nact merci merci
fatimata merci de nous rejoindre alors
la cud aux arbitres nous disent que ça
vous fait justement qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous ce festival vues
d'afrique mais comme je les ai toujours
dit vues d'afrique est un peu une maison
pour moi parce que mes débuts je les
fais aussi avec les d'afrique et le
premier album aussi que j'ai sorti le 30
juin passé le lancement a été fait par
un nuits d'afrique donc c'est vraiment
une maison pour moi quand je suis venu
je me suis identifié à lui l'afrique
parce que ça fait les styles que j'aime
bien et puis il ya une richesse il ya
une diversité est alors pourquoi
mais en fait moi ce que je dirais mon
style c'est un peu c'est de l'afro pop
mais un peu rafraîchi comme j'ai dis
avec du mucci de la rumba congolaise et
de ses veines oui et alors c'est très
particulier oui il faudrait vraiment
l'écouter quelques petites notes 1,15
avoir fait quelques petites notes on a
cappella chanté par de chanter pour nous
ça s'est retourné mini connu en mai un
repas taïbi boulet
on a tokyo un
pipi
[Musique]
alalalala totalement improvisée merci
merci beaucoup nacry total dont vous
êtes attendus dimanche aussi oui
dimanche à 19 heures et 19 heures qu'on
a conféré des de radio-canada pour le
festival c'est bien ça
vers 6 fatimata mais
on va y rester à ce festival nuits
d'afrique de montréal on va se quitter
sans fausse note sur ces images signées
françois rioux et celle du concert de
mokhtar à regagna et quoi nassau écoutez
apprécié passer une excellente nuit sur
france 24 merci de votre idée
[Musique]
mais
et